[Music]
it was march
it started a pandemic we didn't know
anything
it was jam-packed business as usual
people coughing sweating
some people even vomiting at their
workstations
but we just kept working because that's
what we were told to do
my name is chris smalls former amazon
employee
fired on march 30th for holding a
protest
it all started when one of my colleagues
got sick
she was sneezing and had rosy cheeks
as a fellow supervisor i told her to go
home
she did two hours later we had our daily
sync meeting
in this meeting i was told not to tell
my employees that somebody tested
positive
for coleman 19 two weeks prior
after hearing that that's when i took my
stance
i went to tell my employees what was
really going on
i also took action on my own free will i
returned back to the building
sat in the cafeteria for 10 hours a day
telling all the employees the truth
giselle we six feet away yeah put your
foot out
be two feet away social destiny at its
best
from there we march into the general
manager's office
every morning voicing our concerns to
have our demands met
we wanted the building to be closed down
and sanitized
the only only thing we could do to fix
this is called the building okay sir
the only thing yes let me look into that
let me work with uh
two we should make that decision at the
site level where we close or not let me
complete
we are also following the directions of
the cdc which every single company is
just days after organizing i was placed
on a quarantine
not my friends not my colleagues not the
person i ride to work with
just me it was time to organize a real
walkout
at amazon.com staten island fulfillment
center in new york city
known as jfk8 plan to walk off
walk out walk out when amazon workers
walked out of the fulfillment center
warehouse on gulf avenue
workers claim that the company is
mishandling its response to the covet 19
outbreak
we just want the building to be
sanitized honestly it's not safe
it's nowhere near safe this building
needs to shut down i saw people getting
sick every single day
i've been sending people home with
different symptoms we are the heart and
soul of this building
and they're going to treat us with
respect two hours after the protest
i was terminated over the phone for
violating
the quarantine policy 8 14 in this story
getting a whole lot of attention
amazon under fire this morning this
assistant manager who organized a mass
walkout at a distribution center on
staten island new york was
fired today amazon said it was for
allegedly breaking quarantine
not to get rid of a whistleblower but
leaked notes
from an internal meeting days later
which bezos himself was present
showed the company's leadership
discussing plans to make smalls
the face of the entire union organizing
movement
since he is not smart or articulate
which
holy [ __ ] that is so racist
that memo pissed a lot of people off
even within
the company well my name is tim bray and
my title is unemployed bum
because i quit my job last may first
i used to be over at amazon web services
my title there was a vice president and
distinguished engineer
big business headline at home this
morning a canadian vice president of
amazon has resigned in protest
over the company firing whistleblowers
saying the company culture is just
too toxic when it came to firing
whistleblowers you know
uh the the kovit came along amazon was
spending huge amounts of money and
effort trying to make warehouses safer
the workers were still scared about
dying as a result of their work i had no
trouble believing
two things at once that amazon is
working on it but it's still a big
problem
and then they fired the activists who
were trying to do something
about it you can't argue about firing
activists it's just
malevolent and unethical and it's not a
thing that i think
one should be asked to live with and you
know i had a vp rank
and as a vp rank you sort of stand for
the company and i just couldn't be in
tune with that
uh he's quitting in dismay he said that
there was uh that amazon fired
whistleblowers and he's paying the price
for it too
he says he's going to lose a million
dollars in salary in stock options by
making this move
he says that if he didn't do anything he
would be complicit
at the moment we're doing the arithmetic
of costs and benefits
the costs borne by the workers in the
warehouses are just i don't think
adequately costed in and the reason for
that is simple is because they are
relatively powerless
they are fungible they can be replaced
you know if one of them leaves somebody
else can be hired
usually in pretty short order to replace
them and get back on the air so
um the real problem here
is is not a numbers problem it's it's a
power problem it's the disparity in
power between
the very large highly concentrated firms
who dominate the heights of the
big tech economy and the people who do
the
entry-level jobs and and i firmly
believe that if you dislike
the behavior of these companies the only
real solution for that is old-fashioned
politics to you know
find politicians and elect them who will
improve the regulatory and legislative
framework
so that the the behaviors that irritate
us are just no longer acceptable
so here is jeff bezos's company amazon
and they received a tax rebate they paid
nothing
in 2018 in federal taxes
that's a corrupt tax system to begin
with
but then on top of that they received
129
million dollars as a tax rebate so
amazon is the problem the problem isn't
that amazon
is evil the problem is that we have
accepted
a structure of legislation and
regulation
that allows companies like amazon to
play entirely by the rules break no laws
and still
do things that when you look at them
seem like oppression
they thought firing would put it into me
they were
don't know me my name is wrong smalls
former amazon employee that was fired
from
amazon back in march march 30th for
raising health and safety concerns
and now we're here today because we go
on march on this [ __ ] job
and this is what we're about we're about
giving the power back to the workers
putting the power in the workers hand
and letting the workers decide
their own destiny
[Music]
me being a supervisor uh pre-covert
uh building the foundation the
relationship with my employees
something family oriented i carried that
over into this organizing position
um it was easy for me to transition into
this position because
amazon ironically pretty much prepped me
for this
for the last five years when i was
employed i've been a leader there
and when they terminated me they got rid
of one of their best leaders
and they didn't know that but uh now
i think they may know down
i never planned on being an organizer
i was just a concerned supervisor
looking out for people
and i'm going to continue to do that
since then i organized around the
country
i founded my own organization the
congress of essential workers
tcoew to continue to uplift the voices
of
all essential workers welcome chris
smalls
he is organizing amazon workers
when it comes to profit over safety they
will always choose profit
pay your employees a living wage so they
won't have to be on government subsidies
if you go on the website all the
essential items are
are sold out until you restock shut it
down
you have a man that's a billionaire and
they're not being taxed
what part of the game is that tell me
where the right and wrong is in that
i always say it's not going to be amazon
versus chris smalls
it's going to be amazon versus the
[Music]
people
[Music]
you